unicef the united nations children's
fund is warning of a lost decade for
children as the covet-19 pandemic drags
on keeping schools closed and widening
the gap between rich and poor countries
unicef says 100 million more children
have fallen into poverty in the last two
years malnutrition has risen as has
child labor
over 400 million children have been
unable to access remote learning with
many now missing two years of school
these are terrible numbers we're joined
now by james elder he is the unicef
spokesperson in geneva it's good to have
you on the program mr elder covid19 you
say it's the biggest global crisis for
children in the 75 year history of
unicef
what's unicef
telling the world what should be done
yeah it's quite heartbreaking i mean i
think what should be done is a is a an
understanding an acknowledgement of just
how the bad things are for children
across the globe of course we're not
just talking developing world we are
talking from berlin to boston but we are
particularly again
talking about those children at the
margins of society
yet again they've been allowed to fall
through the crack so firstly as an
acknowledgement for people just to
understand that even though everyone's
been doing it tough there are some
people in corners of the globe who
haven't seen any government handouts
haven't seen any online learning any
wi-fi and they've just seen parents lose
jobs they've seen increased stress less
meals more violence and then of course
there are things we can do which come
around you know social welfare and and
better education and so on but it's an
acknowledgement of what's happening to
children right now so we can get away a
little bit from just that this is only
about me in fact it is happening to our
younger citizens at a time when we're
also asking them to you know look after
the planet please and it's hard to
imagine a crisis that could be worse
we've got two years of children
at the same time falling into
malnutrition and missing two years of an
education how do you ever recoup from
that
well it's a very good question it's very
difficult sometimes and mums and dads
around the world in the last decade have
really done everything in their power to
get their children to school we've seen
incredible historic numbers in terms of
children from you know south africa to
senegal
going to school and that's on the back
of organizations like unicef it's on the
back of governments like germany and
it's on the back of mums and dads a lot
of that is being undone right now we're
seeing children out of school we're
seeing as you say malnutrition increase
a lot of children get meals at school
so we need at this point to make sure
one that the vaccine is getting around
the world and two that people
particularly at christmas just remember
that little bit of generosity remember
where those funds can get to because
right now there are there are kids
through no fault of their own who are
doing it tougher than they've ever done
before and they're resilient they didn't
they do tend to find a plan but at the
moment they're they're out of options
and they simply need the sort of support
that unicef seeks to provide i mean what
you're doing is invaluable especially
for the for the future of our planet
but how real is this risk
of us all suffering from a lost
generation
because of what has happened in the past
two years
i think it's i think it's very real when
we look at things like education we look
at mental health of children unicef has
done that again that's from the
developing world across what it's meant
for these children to sit to
to be restricted at home to not be at
school
what a couple of years lost education
does and it's lost education if you
can't get them access online
and remembering at a time that there is
a climate crisis that young people are
very much aware of so
these are the issues now we also know
that things like social welfare social
grants you know investing investing so
that children can get access to online
work even even turning around so we get
more water and sanitation to children in
schools because that helps prevent
covert we do know the solutions to this
but unfortunately and no one likes to
hear it the solutions require money and
yet we know that when we educate a child
there is literally no better investment
you can possibly make and i don't that
mean just that from the heart i mean
that as a practical economic investment
so it's still time to buckle down and
realize that we need to we need to
invest in those younger citizens who
bear no fault for this or any other
crisis yeah and i think as every parent
will tell you you can't even if you have
a lot of money you can't buy back the
time that you've lost james elder
spokesperson for unicef joining us
tonight from geneva mr evans we
appreciate your time and what you're
doing thank you